Morgen.
Ja fahre ins Mittelmeer habe ich super Angebot bekommen mit Bootsfahrt ja von so einem Asyl Tourismus Discounter.
Logbuch Netzpolitik in Nummer 259 vom 22 Juni 2018 die Tage werden wieder kürzer.
Weißt du wie stolz ich bin dass er das jetzt in endlich hinkriegen mit diesem Datums ansagen ja.
Ich auch das wurde mir ein Jahrzehnt lang vorgeworfen zurecht unseres merkwürdig wie schwierig das ist das in den Apparat reinzubekommen aber wenn es dann einmal drin ist.
Wann muss ich die eben die Metaebene als Apparat ja bis der so bis da so ein Änderungsvorschlag mal seinen Weg durch die Strukturen geschaffen hat na da müssen ja dann auch erstmal,
bis das bis das wirklich der Apparat dann übernommen hat ne das ist dann kurz bevor die EU-Regulierung zuschlägt und das verpflichtend Macht kommt dann eine freiwillige Selbstverpflichtung der Metaebene und dann.
Irgendwann ist.
Das nicht irgendwann muss der Grundverordnung her.
Genau da gibt's zum Mittag eben den Grundverordnung und dann wird das Projekt zum Prozess und dann ist das Linie aber.
Nenne das wird dann erstmal zwei Jahre lang nicht gemacht solange bis die Strafzahlungen dann auch verpflichtend sind.
Ist alle das Memo bekommen habe.
Und gelesen haben tja naja gut.
Kleiner Spoiler heute geht unter anderem auch um Europa und wir werden uns dann auch gleich noch einen Gast dazuschalten vorher denke ich ist es aber angemessen.
Noch einmal aufs Feedback zu blicken allerdings so viel.
Ruhige Zeit glaube ich nicht zu sagen denn gefühlt hat sich das Feedback der letzten Sendung zu 99% um unsere messenger Diskussion gedreht.
Da gab es dann viele nachvollziehbare Hinweise zu alternativen und was man sonst noch nehmen könnte und was denn angeblich schon standardisiert sein und wie gut doch die Standards dann Jahre später mit den kommerziellen Anbietern mithalten würden.
Ja
Hilft halt nicht jetzt keiner benutzt.
Ist halt das.
Ehrlich gesagt wollen wir dieses kussion jetzt ja auch nicht groß öffnen wir nehmen da eure Kommentare zur Kenntnis ich denke dass wir vieles davon auch im Prinzip schon.
Angeschnitten haben es wird halt immer wieder festgestellt dass es.
Open Source offene Standards Alternativen gibt wie auch immer sie jetzt heißen mögen und was die einzelnen dann halt vorzogen gibt's anhaltende Fraktionen da gibt's nichts FDP-Fraktion ergibt eine Mastodon Fraktion und so weiter und.
Dieser vielklang an der Stelle ist halt auch Teil des Problems weil.
Da gibt's viele Inseln aber in diesen netzwerkeffekt sitzen sich halt daneben die Systeme erstmal durch wo alle sind und gewonnen haben die die am besten alle da erstmal hinbekommen haben.
Das ist richtig und es gibt glaube ich noch einen.
Sehr entscheidende nen anderen. Den der gerne vergessen wird die erfolgreichen Ende zu Ende,
Verschlüsselungs Angebote ja also WhatsApp Wassermann ihr seid immer so bezeichnen muss secret threema.
IMessage.
Die haben den Vorteil dass bei ihnen sowohl das Routing als auch die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung in einem Paket kommen.
Und dass sie haben also einen Mechanismus die haben auf den auf allen diesen Messenger und dann eben diese Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung und sie haben custom in ihre Art des Protokolls eingebaut dass sich einen Client.
Bin den Schlüssel von dem anderen holt das die Nachrichten damit verschlüsselt werden und so das ist einmal alles aus einem Guss und.
XMPP ja ist eben nur ein message Routing,
so und wenn man dann sagt darüber verschlüsseln wird dann benutzt man eben OTR oder nicht und wenn der kleinen das am anderen Ende nicht kann dann kann man es eben auch nicht benutzen kann auch irgendwie,
die Gypsy über XMPP sprechen kannst alles machen kannst auch deine eigene Gruppe da drauf machen das ist alles sehr schön und gut und das ist auch theoretisch erstmal interoperabel.
Du hast nur am Ende eine ganze Reihe an corner cases wenn jetzt jemand sagt ich möchte von meinem threema Messenger,
an einer Signal Identität schreiben DIN vollständig anderes Routing haben die vollständig andere Adressierung haben die eine andere Verschlüsselungen haben den anderes key management also im Sinne von,
Keyserver und wo man sich einen Schlüssel holen muss oder eben auch nicht die all das haben und das wird man nicht mehr interoperabel bekommen und das ist auch so gewünscht.
Mission und vor allem diesen also nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich aus einer.
Marktperspektive absolut sinnvoll und notwendig das dann zu erzwingen ich finde den Vorschlag von Katarina barley sehr gut.
Das ist wichtig dass das dass man diese,
marktbeherrschenden Stellung in aufweicht und dass man sie dazu Interoperabilität zwingt damit überhaupt noch andere eine Schnitte bekommen können,
denn das ist das was die was die kleinen messenger an der Verbreitung hindert dass man sagt,
was soll ich mit diesem Messenger wenn ich darüber niemanden erreiche würde nun ein schöner messenger sagen ja pass auf hier bei uns kannst Du auch zu WhatsApp schreiben dann ist das natürlich ein entscheidendes feature.
Alsi10mg würde aber eigentlich davon ausgehen dass das.
Mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit mit irgendwelchen Einschränkungen einhergehen würde die Wasser sich die Form der nachrichten die man versendet betreffen können die die Verschlüsselung betreffen können und die am Ende dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder beim.
Einband Spam.
Bestellbestätigung Gaggenau Spam ist auch noch so ein Aspekt also die Probleme sind vielfältig und schwer.
Lösen und das, jetzt beklagen das tun wir auch aber es nur mal die Situation in der wir sind und ich habe da wenig Hoffnung dass der schnell erinnern wird nächstes.
Also wenn dann auf jeden Fall durch durch regulation durch durch Regulierung und Gesetz von alleine auf gar keinen Fall.
Ja richtig und man kann da ja auch mit kleinen Schritten schon was bewirken und ich denke eine große Keule kann man jetzt auch gar nicht groß,
auspacken weil die würde erstens sowieso auf den letzten Metern hobbymäßig zerpflückt werden und am Ende einfach mehr noyens als Hilfe sein.
Aber wenn man es halt mit kleinen Sachen macht über die Zeit.
Wo hier Mindestanforderung da Mindestanforderung da das schrittweise Nachsteuer dann kann man es bis abmildern aber es wird.
Nicht generell die Koordinaten komplett verschieben können andererseits hat sich ja auch schon viel verbessern also.
Man kann sich halt auch nur auf dem Markt behaupten.
Wenn man daneben auch nach regelt also hätte whatsapp eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung nicht eingeführt und seid auch generell gesagt dass sie das nicht tun wollen dann werden Sie daran gescheitert.
Im aktuellen.
Ja
Mittlerweile denke ich kann man das sagen also heute kannst kannst du überhaupt nicht mehr ernsthaft als Player auftreten wenn du sowas eben nicht als Mindestanforderung hast und.
Datenschutz wird jetzt gibt's halt ein ähnlichen Druck an der Stelle das man eben.
Bestimmte Mindestanforderungen erfüllen muss und sicherlich sind da auch Schritte in der Interoperabilität vorstellbar aber dieses.
Wenn man nur X bei dem Protokoll ändern würde dann wäre ja schon alles anders das kam halt in den Kommentaren mit E-Mail und wenn Outlook dies tun würde und wenn man alle dazu zwingen würde.
E-Mail ist wirklich das schlechteste Beispiel II schlechtes Beispiel was.
Aufgaben behalte die ganze Situation um HTML ich meine schau dir an wie lange es da gedauert hat bis man sich überhaupt erstmal auf irgendwas,
geeinigt hat und letzten Endes sind auch gerade die Vorschläge der Komitees gescheitert,
also so aussehen also XHTML und sowas die großen Visionen der der Schöpfer sind komplett gegen die Wand gefahren auch aus ähnlichen Gründen auch weil sie einfach eingesehen haben dass man sich einfach in sum Legacy Umfeld nicht.
Nichtmitte.
Stell dir vor es ist Standard und keiner macht mit.
Nervend gesagt du musst mit dem nicht nicht dazu hin.
Convert wanna Problem stell dir vor es ist Standard und alle machen mit mir eine E-Mail bekommen.
Ich wollte nur kurz,
ein Rezept abholen Standardprozedur alle sechs Monate mein Kind mich allerdings hat der Arzt jetzt die neuen Terminals dieser Sex Parität der Gesundheitskarte online mit der GKV abgleichen also wenn man so eine Karte hat wenn man von der Krankenkasse eine Karte bekommt steht drauf,
die ist bis dann und dann gültig kann ja aber sein dass man inzwischen die Krankenkasse gewechselt hat oder sowas deswegen gleichen diese Terminals online ab leuchtet ja erstmal ein.
DKV gesetzlicher Kranken.
Energetiker das was man beim Arzt braucht.
Eine offline Methode scheint es nicht zu geben ich hatte meine Karte dabei gültig bis 2022 aber bei meiner GKV gab es anscheinend ein Schluckauf in der Datenbank denn meine Karte wurde abgelehnt und so ging es auf vielen anderen Kunden derselben,
Versicherung mal kann Versicherer an bitte Sie eine Versicherungsbestätigung an die Praxis zu faxen geht nicht.
Den Faxe kommen natürlich beim Server an und der ist gerade ausgefallen e-mail an die Praxis geht,
denn die Praxis hat angeblich keine E-Mail-Adresse rufe meine Krankenkasse erneut an und bitte Sie eine Versicherungsbestätigung an mich zu mailen und zeige der Sprechstundenhilfe die Bestätigung auf meinem handy wird abgelehnt die könnte man nämlich nur,
ausgedruckt akzeptieren.
Navi bei der Bahn ihr.
Ich biete an die Datei als PDF auf einem USB-Stick zu überreichen damit sie es sich ausdrücken können wir abgelehnt klar usb-c katja.fun machen,
bitte an die Ausstellung des Rezeptes in bar zu bezahlen wird abgelehnt wann bist du ja wissen dass ich versichert sein nach einer Stunde entschuldigt er sich der Arzt.
Betont dass das neue System jetzt vom Gesetzgeber vorgeschrieben sei gib mir die E-Mail-Adresse der Praxis druckt das PDF aus und gibt mir das Rezept.
Auf Nachfrage antwortet die Gagas übrigens sie können einen Arzttermin ohne gültigen Versicherungsnachweis wahrnehmen hierbei darf der Arzt eine,
Privatrechnung für die Behandlung ausstellen nach der Behandlung haben sie 10 Tage maximal bis Quartalsende Zeit um eine Versicherungsbestätigung beim Arzt nachzureichen.
Streichen der Arzt ist dann dazu verpflichtet die Kosten mit uns abzurechnen also wissen Bescheid alles gar kein Problem nächste mal zum Arzt gehen einfach ein bisschen mehr Zeit mitbringen.
An der sehen wir sind eben in der Zukunft.
Und vielleicht nicht gerade am letzten Tag des Quartals beteuern.
Kenne ich kenne das Problem aus aus anderer Situation weil ich mir da mal längere Zeit Auseinandersetzung hatte wegen des Bilder zwangsstehen ich für mich nicht aus religiösen Gründen nicht,
akzeptieren konnte auf der Gesundheitskarte.
Und das war auch ein langes hin und her aber ich habe das in der Regel dann bei der Krankenkasse angerufen und das rüber Faxen lassen aber dafür braucht man eben ein Faxgerät was bei der Krankenkasse nicht ausgefallen ist.
Faxgerät.
Da denkt man doch direkt ans EU-Parlament.
Ja na ja gut vielleicht also genau können wir nach Europa.
In Europa und wartet ja schon in der vorletzten Sendung mit thomas.
Ausführlich darüber gesprochen und abends auch noch mal aufgegriffen stand jetzt die.
Entscheidungen zum Thema Urheberrecht hviezda weitergeben soll was die Stellungnahme des Parlaments ist und wie wird es vielleicht schon gehört haben ist erstmal alles nicht so gut.
Ausgegangen.
Und um uns dieses ganze Themenfeld ein wenig besser erläutern zu lassen schalten wir doch einfach mal direkt,
nach Europa und begrüßen jetzt die Julia am Telefon Julia Räder vom EU-Parlament julia war schon.
Einige Male bei uns zu Gast unter anderem bei der 150 Sendung und zuletzt auch im Januar noch mal um genau über dieses Thema auch zu sprechen hallo Julia.
Hallo.
Ja das war eine wilde Tage oder in im Parlament.
Ja also wird Geschäftsordnung Schlachten und einstimmen Mehrheiten haben wir heute alles Drama gehabt diese Woche was man sich so vorstellen kann,
und das Ergebnis aus dem Ausschuss zum Urheberrecht ist echt katastrophal aber ich bin noch guter Dinge dass wir das im Plenum noch mal kippen können.
Gut ich denke es ist an dieser Stelle aber auch noch mal wert das Ding komplett.
Aufzurollen also was ja und korrigiere mich wenn ich das jetzt nicht richtig zusammenfasse was ja passiert ist ist nun seit längerem diese Reform des Urheberrechts auf europäischer Ebene.
Geplant und diskutiert worden hier ist der Rechtsausschuss primär zuständig im Europäischen Parlament.
Wann ist ja immer so dass diese Ausschüsse wie man das eben geeinigt auch vom Bundestag her kennt.
Wesentlichen die politische Vorarbeit leisten das heißt dort werden die Gesetze ausgearbeitet oder die bzw die Stellungnahmen zu den Gesetzesvorschläge der Europäischen Kommission ausgearbeitet und.
Ja
Längere Zeit abgezeichnet dass im Rahmen dieser Reform vor allem zwei sehr unangenehme Dinge mit ins Spiel kommen nämlich einerseits die Einführung eines Leistungsschutzrecht und andererseits halt.
Die Einführung von upload-filter sprich eine Verpflichtung der Provider oder Seitenbetreiber.
Gleich noch mal kurz erklären was da jetzt alles die aktuelle Definition ist.
Ja quasi Inhalte bevor sie das Internet betreten schon auf potenzielle Urheberrechtsverstöße hin ab zu klopfen so und dazu gab es ja diese Woche eine entsprechende Abstimmung spricht dieser.
Ausschuss hat seine.
Ja sein letztes Statement abgegeben zu diesem Thema was man denn nun vorschlägt in die Verhandlungen mit der Kommission zu tragen und da ist es ein bisschen.
Knapp und blöd ausgegangen habe ich das soweit erstmal richtig zusammengefasst.
Ja das ist genau richtig also eigentlich läuft es im Parlament meistens relativ konsensorientiert ab und es ist auch so ein bisschen Aufgabe des Ausschusses und des Berichterstatters.
Diesen Konsens zu suchen davon hat aber unser Berichterstatter Axel Voss,
CDU irgendwie wenig gehalten und wollte stattdessen mit dem Kopf durch die Wand auf keinen Fall irgendwie vom Leistungsschutzrecht abrücken obwohl die Kritik immer lauter geworden ist,
und das hat eben dazu geführt dass er am Ende.
Mit 13 zu 12 Stimmen das Leistungsschutzrecht durch den Ausschuss gebracht hat also eigentlich nur von Gnaden des Front National also die beiden.
Außen Abgeordneten im Rechtsausschuss Wandervögel stimmt und nur deshalb hat er überhaupt nicht mehr Halt bekommen und.
Das könnte ihm jetzt aber eben in auf die Füße fallen weil das ganze Parlament,
Anfang Juli ja noch mal entscheiden darf ob sie denn dieses Ausschuss Ergebnis jetzt akzeptieren oder nicht,
und ja also es gab durchaus immer wieder Versuche zu sagen wir können ja irgendwie einen Kompromiss finden bei dem das freie Internet nicht gefährdet wird und trotzdem irgendwie,
den Verlagen und der Musikindustrie am Ende irgendwas übrig bleibt aber dazu war er vor seid überhaupt nicht willens.
Und deshalb haben wir jetzt diesen wirklich katastrophalen Text Wo Upload Filter drin sind wo Leistungsschutz.
Trensen und was vielleicht auch nicht allen so klar ist also das finde ich nur upload-filter sondern diese Plattformen.
Unmittelbar haftbar für jede einzelne Urheberrechtsverletzung ihrer Nutzer das heißt selbst wenn sie irgendwie den neuesten Stand an filtern.
Verlieren die sowieso mehr schlecht als recht funktionieren sobald sie eine Urheberrechtsverletzung nicht erkennen sind sie trotzdem dran.
Also.
Anreize für diese Plattform soviel zu filtern wie nur irgendwie möglich und immer dann wenn auch nur der leise.
Zweifel an der Legalität besteht dass von vornherein nicht zuzulassen also im Prinzip eine Vorzensur zu betreiben denn das ist die einzige Art und Weise wie sie sich nach diesem Vorschlag vor der Haftung Schutz.
Wer ist denn dann also ich meine wer ist denn hier quasi in der Pflicht also was ist hier vivii wie ist die Definition für wen das gilt also wer muss solche Haftung.
Also diese Definition besagt zunächst einmal dass es um Hosting-Provider geht also sie müssen die Inhalte sowohl speichern als auch öffentlich anzeigen das heißt also,
Rheine.
Streaming-Dienste wären davon womöglich nicht erfasst weil sie eben die Inhalte nicht dauerhaft speichern und reine sage ich mal Cloud-Dienste die.
Ausschließlich mit Passwort Zugang gewähren und eben keinen öffentlichen Zugang machen die sind auch draußen aber alle anderen Hosting-Provider sind zunächst mal drin.
Dann wird gesagt okay also es geht um die Hosting-Provider deren Zweck ist ist oder einer ihrer Hauptwerke öffentlichen Zugang zu gewähren.
Das ist meiner Ansicht nach keinen keinen besonders sinnvolles Kriterium um die Definition weiter einzuschränken weil ich denke mir nachher was ist denn der Zweck von Facebook z.b.
Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie die die.
Kunden von Facebook fragen würde die Werbetreibenden dann würden die wahrscheinlich sagen der Zweck von Facebook ist irgendwie Werbung möglichst gezielt an ihre.
Ziele auszuliefern.
Die Nutzer von Facebook würden wahrscheinlich sagen irgendwie der Zwerg ist mit meinen Freunden zu kommunizieren keine Ahnung also das ist ein sehr schwammiges Kriterium und könnte dazu führen dass auf der einen Seite,
so eine Plattform wie Kinder davon betroffen ist wenn man sagt na ja.
Also Kinder hat eigentlich keinen anderen Zweck als Leuten Fotos anzuzeigen das ist irgendwie der Kern dessen was diese App macht aber auf der anderen Seite könnte sein dass Facebook das eigentlich das Ziel dieses Vorschlags war gar nicht betroffen ist.
Weil man sagt nachher der Zweck von Facebook ist eigentlich ein anderer also dieser Zweck.
Meiner Ansicht nach stiftet nur Verwirrung und führt nicht dazu irgendwie zu sagen es ist gar nicht so schlimm.
Und bestimmte Plattform müssen sich keine Sorgen machen und dann gibt's das dritte Kriterium das dritte Kriterium ist.
Diese Plattform die Inhalte nicht einfach nur Husten sondern auch optimieren allerdings ist optimieren so breit definiert.
Das auch so ziemlich alles runterfällt also es wird gesagt optimieren ist z.b. taggen oder displaying also unter displaying stelle ich mir so vor naja also z.b. wenn es kein reiner file locker ist.
Sondern wenn ich das Video oder die MP3 unmittelbar im Browser abspielen kann dann ist das bereits in Optimierung also insofern da wird auch außer ganz ganz simple file or kann eigentlich nicht.
Abgeschlossen das heißt also von dieser Definition sind erstmal so ziemlich alle Provider erfasst und dann gibt es ganz ganz.
Fehrle Ausnahmen und zwar Dienst.
Die mit einem nicht kommerziellen Zweck addieren und Dienste wo sowieso alle recht Inhaber zugestimmt haben die sind drauf.
Und dann wird noch gesagt also.
Die Cloud Services und die online marketplaces sind.
Also das heißt auf der einen Seite eine äh,
lehmbreite Definition und auf der anderen Seite.
So sag mal dein ok alle außer Wikipedia eventuell noch Gitter und eBay.
Also das heißt mein Mann nimmt mir Definition wo erstmal alle drin sind und dann hat sich irgendeine Lobby beschwert um gesagt nee sorry aber für Ebay geht das jetzt wirklich nicht und dann hat man halt geschrieben okay aber ebay ist nicht gemeint.
Das Problem mit diesem mit diesem mit dieser Herangehensweise ist natürlich dass man nur die Plattform ausnehmen kann die man heute schon kennt aber alle die irgendwie Überherrn post,
Erkenntnishorizont hinausgehen weil er von denen noch nie gehört hat oder weil die vielleicht auch noch gar nicht existieren die werden dann filtern müssen.
Und die keinen keinen Lobbyisten zum gegebenen Zeitpunkt vor Ort hatten der mal kurz bei uns vorbei geht und sagt immer das Fieber.
Gesagt jetzt.
Ich bin nur ganz kurze du hast gerade gesagt reine Streaming-Anbieter damit meinst du jemanden der jetzt quasi es geht ja auch immer um User generierte Inhalte na das heißt jemand der wirklich nur also Streaming. Media CCC de.
Im Gegensatz zu Media CCC de ne boah wo die Sachen auch gespeichert werden und nachher noch mal abrufbar sind.
Genau also in der Definition steht drin.
To store and give access also posten und Zugang geben das heißt also wenn eine Plattform tatsächlich die Inhalte nicht speichert.
Abgesehen hat von der Sekunde in der sie irgendwie gestreamt werden dann wäre die Plattform nicht drin aber jeder Streaming Provider der auch noch irgendwie eine Zeitverzögerung anbietet oder dergleichen der wäre schon von der Definition erfasst.
Und es ist nicht so dass man durch das Installieren von Upload filtern der Haftung entkommen kann.
Nein das wäre ja zu einfach.
Das war aber doch zwischenzeitlich auch mal stand doch auch mal zur Debatte oder.
Das ist was der Rat fordert also man kann dem rad zumindest zugute halten das ist zumindest theoretisch möglich ist für eine Plattform den Forderungen des Rates zu entsprechen.
Ist zwar nicht gut und es verstößt wahrscheinlich gegen Grundrechte die Plattform zum Filtern zu verpflichten aber wenigstens sagt der Rat also naja wenn die Plattform schon filtert dann ist sie auch aus der Haftung raus.
Das Parlament also der Text von Herrn Voß ist wirklich ja so radikal dass selbst die Plattform die alle Filter,
am Ende immer noch verklagt werden kann weil jeder einzelne Urheberrechtsverletzung die durch den Filter durch schlüpft sofort.
Der Plattform selbst zu gerechnet werden kann und das ist eigentlich noch die viel radikalere Änderung im Grunde genommen weil die das Hosting-Provider Privileg also die Regelung.
Das Provider erst dann haften wenn Sie Kenntnis erlangen davon dass jemand was illegales tut also das komplett abschafft für Urheberrecht und das ist eigentlich schon Wirklichkeit.
Ja fand das ist ja auch Kramer mal in den letzten Jahren etwas gewesen was ich eigentlich Zug-um-Zug immer so ein bisschen verbessert hat dass man diese para.
Ja und wenn man überlegt.
Ja also so in Deutschland also es gab so auch viel Kritik am netzdg aber der wird trotzdem schon gesagt also irgendwie Haftung gibt,
nur dann wenn es regelmäßig und systematisch Fehler passieren und nicht wenn einmal eine hassbotschaft durchkommt.
Wie wird noch mal kurz weil.
Darf ich die ganze europäische Prozess ja viele aber nicht so ganz klar ist man die Gesetzesinitiative also der Beschluss hier überhaupt etwas anzugehen und ja immer von der Kommission,
wie verhält sich denn jetzt oder und am Schluss muss es halt mit dem rad also in diesem Trilog ausgehandelt werden sprich auch das was jetzt das Parlament.
Beschließt ist jetzt noch nicht das Endergebnis sondern das Endergebnis ist das was Kommission Parlament und Rat.
Aushandeln als das finale Ergebnis jetzt sagt so ok der Rat ist in einer Stelle etwas weniger giftig wie verhält sich denn das was das Parlament jetzt beschlossen hat zu dem was die Kommission ursprünglich vorgeschlagen hat.
Also im ursprünglichen Kommissionsvorschlag gab es eine Verpflichtung zum Filtern aber keine Haftung.
Das heißt also die große Veränderungen gegenüber dem Kommissionsvorschlag ist eben dass die Plattform unmittelbar für die Urheberrechtsverletzungen ihrer User haften.
Im Kommissionsvorschlag war das noch so dass ihm gesagt wurde also sie sind verpflichtet.
Filtern und dann wurde in den Erwägungsgründen so ein bisschen argumentiert also dass sie womöglich ja auch nach geltender Rechtslage eh schon haftbar sind aber das stand nicht so.
Glasklar im Text wie das jetzt im Parlament und Rat der Fall ist.
Ist ja eigentlich auch schon mal was Neues dass das Parlament da jetzt noch schärfer rangeht an einem Gesetz oder.
Also das muss man ganz klar sagen und das ist glaube ich auch der Grund weshalb ist gute Chancen gibt das im Plenum noch zu kippen weil hairforce hat einfach.
Übertrieben also er hat einen Kompromiss vorgelegt der radikaler ist als jeder einzelne Änderungsantrag der überhaupt eingereicht wurde und nennt das dann irgendwie einen einen Kompromiss.
Dann muss man sich nicht wundern wenn die Mehrheiten extrem knapp sind und das fehlt um das vielleicht anders.
Und der Frauen national war jetzt das Zünglein an der Waage das finde ich ja auch beim.
Beim Upload Filter leider nicht also beim upload-filter war es schlimmer da war es 15 zusehen dass er selbst wenn er vor Nachhinein nicht zugestimmt hätte wäre das,
bekommen weil dort die Konservativen also die Tories,
zugestimmt haben beim Leistungsschutzrecht haben aber die Konservativen dagegen gestimmt und da ging es entsprechend 13.12 aus und es lag ausschließlich an den Stimmen also an den zwei Stimmen bevor national.
Na grandios.
Jetzt wird mich immer interessieren du hast doch an diesen Ausschusssitzungen auch teilgenommen oder was treibt die um.
Wie also wie kommen die.
Ich bin hier gerade mal so ein bisschen auf auf der Webseite von Axel Forst die begrüßt Anja schon mit Europa muss handeln Datenschutz im Spannungsfeld zwischen Digitalisierung und Terrorbekämpfung,
wo ist der große klassische Floskeln dann auf einmal mit mit mit mit diesen Angst Buzzwords verwende vermischt werden NRW,
da weiß man schon wo man jetzt gerade wieder gelandet ist ne aber wie argumentieren die also Essig.
Er sagt ja auch Urheberrecht muss fair sein Post vom 20.06 ja feiert ja auch seinen RV.
Alle also fair vor allen Dingen für die die Plattform verklagen wollen die mich an also die Argument hat,
Sohn von Herrn Voß ist nicht besonders stringent weil der ein oder andere wird ihn schon kennen aus den Verhandlungen zur Datenschutz,
Grundverordnung und da war er der,
und so weiter und das scheint ihn aber überhaupt nicht zu interessieren wenn es jetzt um ums Urheberrecht geht also ist,
keinerlei mildernde Maßnahmen für Kleinunternehmen in diesem Vorschlag im Gegensatz zum Rat der zumindest sagt na ja.
Also wenn es ein ganz kleine Plattform ist dann reicht möglicherweise eben auch dass man die Inhalte im Nachhinein entfernt sowas,
hier nicht also es ist keine so richtige Logik zu erkennen dass hairforce jetzt grundsätzlich immer.
Wie freundlich wäre oder oder irgendwas in der Art weil.
Also die gleichen Unternehmen die Herford irgendwie bei der datenschutzgrundverordnung verteidigt hat.
Kommen und so weiter die schmeißt er jetzt hier vor dem Bus also insofern ist das nicht so ganz.
Also aus den Diskussionen in den Verhandlungsrunden ist so ein bisschen hervorgegangen das hervor.
Mit vielen der Plattformen die von seinem Vorschlag betroffen sind einfach nicht vertraut ist.
Er hat mal gesagt also tinder oder GitHub hat er noch nie benutzt er kennt die eigentlich nicht und ich habe mal in einer Verhandlungsrunde.
Eine halbe Stunde damit verbracht handfaust zu versuchen zu überzeugen das geht hab eine Firma ist und keine nicht-kommerzielle Plattform.
Und also das zumindest hat funktioniert und im Text geschrieben drin das irgendwie Open-Source-Software developing platforms.
Nicht betroffen sein sollen immerhin aber das war wirklich eine halbe Stunde hin und her weil der wirklich überzeugt davon war GitHub wäre irgendwie ein nicht kommerzielles Community Projekt oder so einfach nur weil Leute das kostenfrei benutzen können.
Also das ist auch.
Facebook auch ist auch community.
Ja ja aber also dass das irgendwie sehr schwierig weil also ich glaube.
Seine Herangehensweise ist also wenn eine Firma Geld verdient und wenn.
Der Upload von user-generated-content irgendwie centralis für ihr Geschäftsmodell dann müssen da ja irgendwo Urheber ausgebeutet werden.
Also ich habe dann versucht ihm das.
Beispiel Kinder zu erklären wo selbstverständlich Kinder nicht funktionieren würde wenn Leute dort keine urheberrechtlich geschützten Inhalte hochladen könnten also Fotos aber das deshalb trotzdem keine Fotografen hungern.
Weil irgendwie Kinder in keine Lizenzgebühren zahlt denn in aller Regel laden die Leute da halt ihre selfies hoch.
Die überhaupt nicht irgendwie von professionellen Fotografen gemacht wurden oder so aber das ist irgendwie das ist ihm nicht vertraut also.
Wie viel viel viel klarer kann ich es auch nicht erklären warum das so ist.
Aber für ihn sind Online-Plattformen eben YouTube und Facebook und die haben schon genug Geld und die benutzen ja auch schon fehlte aber da fehlt dann auch das Verständnis dass die Filter die z.b. YouTube benutzt.
Bei weitem nicht in der Lage sind alle möglichen Urheberrecht.
Zu erkennen also Content-ID ist schon irgendwie state-of-the-art und kann nicht nur genau also exakte Kopien von Videos erkennen sonst z.b. auch Melodien.
Das ist schon relativ technisch versiert aber das war's dann auch also wenn z.b. jemand in einem.
Youtube-Video ein Gedicht vorliest oder womöglich noch ein Gedicht das in eine andere Sprache übersetzt wurde.
Von hier.
Ja so dann kann Content-ID das selbstverständlich nicht erkennen und also das heißt diese Technologie die da gefordert wird die gibt es eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Noch dazu.
Dass er sich der der oder wenn ich das richtig verstehe es sich der Tatsache bewusst dass nur diese beiden sehr großen Plattformen überhaupt Ablaut Filtersysteme gebaut haben rühmt also dachte auch sehr ganz toll,
wie funktioniert ja super und Sohnemann dir sogar schon freiwillig und alle anderen sollen sich da dann einfach mit dran Knoten.
Ja also das ist auch so ein so ein blinder Fleck in der Argumente,
John der Verfechter von Artikel 13 weil es wird ja gesagt also alle die gegen Artikel 13 sind in der jetzigen Form das sind irgendwie die Vasallen von Google und.
Aber wir hatten letzte Woche eine Anhörung im Binnenmarkt Ausschuss zum Thema illegale Inhalte und die einzigen die dort positiv über algorithmische Filter gesprochen haben wann Google und face.
Die kleine Unternehmen die Akademiker die Zivilgesellschaft sagen alle diese Filter sind in Holz.
Und führen massenhaft zu Verletzungen der Meinungsfreiheit und sind vor allen Dingen nachteilig für Randgruppen also da kam dann solche Beispiele wie das z.b.
Menschen die auf Arabisch oder in kyrillischer Schrift kommunizieren ganz oft Opfer von irgendwelchen Filtersystemen werden weil die halt denken das wären Terroristen oder das wären russische boards.
Einfach weil das halt die Daten hergeben mit denen diese Algorithmen trainiert wurden.
Ich kann natürlich auch verstehen warum Google und Facebook sagen ja finden wir super ich meine diese Unternehmen.
Sind seit Jahren seit ihrem Bestehen ist deren Weiterentwicklung,
neue Daten zu finden ja und wenn jemand anderes Daten hat wenn irgendwo anderes Unternehmen in signifikanter Größe genutzt werden dann dann kaufen Sie diese Unternehmen mitunter ja also beispielsweise,
19 Milliarden für WhatsApp wenn nun das EU-Parlament sagt passt auf die Daten.
Didi anhäufen die etwas dass ich in Linus kleinen sozialnetzwerk genutzt werden da wird jetzt - kleines soziales Netzwerk,
verpflichtet die einmal durch euren upload-filter zu schicken,
so dass alle Inhalte die die Leute die jetzt über diesen asozialen Netzwerks etwas für euch immer noch so ein hässlicher schwarzer Fleck auf der Internet Landkarte war ja liegt die denn jetzt verpflichten auch noch bei euch durch geschickt.
Dann habt ihr da auch noch mal den die Einsicht und wir können außerdem noch eine erzwungene Dienstleistungen für dieses andere soziale Netzwerke bringen und kriegt dafür Kosten,
los deren Inhalte einfach frei Haus ja da würde ich als gut,
Google Facebook Aussagen so du gar kein Thema also gar kein Problem die Konkurrenz einfach auch Ihre Daten bei uns rein füttern da müssen wir die Konkurrenz nicht kaufen ja dann haben wir diese da.
Es hat ja bei der CDU schon gute Tradition Gesetze zu verabschieden die angeblich irgendwie Google an den Kragen gehen sollen und am Ende Google stärken also es ist ja beim Leistungsschutzrecht wirklich genau dasselbe Dilemma.
Aber sie lernen es einfach nicht.
Leistungsschutzrecht haben er war ja der andere traurige Artikel hier jetzt ne und ist das richtig dass das Leistungsschutzrecht EWS unveräußerlich sein soll.
Nicht direkt also damit hat sich ja Forstern doch nicht so in der Gänze durchsetzen können also in seinem ersten Entwurf stand drin dass es unveräußerlich das heißt also ein Verleger muss Geld dafür verlangen ob er will oder nicht.
Das ist jetzt doch ein bisschen abgeschwächt worden also jetzt steht drin.
Also dieses Leistungsschutzrecht soll dazu führen dass die Verlage faire Vergütung erwerben können.
Dann steht aber in den Erwägungsgründen die das ganze erklären übrigens das Listen in einer Suchmaschine ist aber keine faire Vergütung.
Also mit anderen Worten sie finden das irgendwie nicht ok was in Deutschland passiert ist nämlich dass Google eine gratis.
Bekommen hat aber sie haben auch keine Lösung wie man das verhindern kann weil sie wollen die Verlage nicht zwingen Geld zu verlangen.
Wir wollen aber gleichzeitig sagen nee also das geht aber nicht dass das Google dann umsonst kriegt nur wie das funktionieren soll das auf der einen Seite die Verlage entscheiden können ob sie Geld verlangen oder nicht das aber auf der anderen Seite google doch auf jeden Fall zahlen muss.
Das ist völlig unter also es ist Seiten im Quatsch Text irgendwie.
Ja es ist irgendwie auch Wirtschaft richtig finde ich das irgendwie sehr interessant ne weil wenn jetzt um die Unternehmen kostenlose Lizenzen rausgeben also wenn man so,
dem Finanzamt gegenüber sagt so ja hier habe ich einem anderen Unternehmen ganz viel kostenlos gegeben da kommen die halt ganz schnell an und sagen naja ist das jetzt hier vielleicht eine Schenkung oder so ja wird jetzt hier irgendwas erschlichen,
und auch bei den upload-filter ne also ich meine klar Google Facebook können natürlich jetzt erstmal sagen hier kein Problem stehen wir euch,
los bereit wenn dann aber klar ist dass diese Daten nicht genutzt werden können und der von Linus wogende Vorteil vielleicht wegfällt können die halt auch schnell sagen ja das kostet aber auch alles ganz schön viel Geld,
ihr müsst jetzt hier uns auch Geld dafür bezahlen wir sind die einzigen die hier konform sind und vielleicht doch die einzigen die jemals bleiben werden uns müsst auf absehbare Zeit man zwingt ja geradezu die europäische Wirtschaft,
bei Google und Facebook mit Dienstleistung einzukaufen.
Ja also ich meine ich glaube das muss inzwischen.
Zumindest den Leuten die für das Leistungsschutzrecht lobbyieren auch irgendwie bewusst sein also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass der Axel-Springer-Verlag wirklich immer noch glaubt dass Google am Ende bezahlen wird.
Manche meiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen glauben das vielleicht wirklich und stimmt deshalb für das Leistungsschutz.
Aber also ich glaube bei Springer ist die Erkenntnis inzwischen dann doch auch durchgesickert da muss man sich natürlich die Frage stellen warum wollen die das.
Tim immer noch öfters bekommen raus durchdrücken und da hatten wir eine ganz interessante Anhörung im Rechtsausschuss also wo ein Anwalt von Axel Springer uns als unabhängiger Experte präsentiert wurde vom von der Parlament Verwaltung.
Und der hat gesagt es geht beim Leistungsschutzrecht überhaupt nicht da drum dass irgendjemand Lizenzgebühren zahlen soll sondern es geht da drum.
Nachrichten Aggregatoren und Suchmaschinen einfach vom Markt zu verdrängen.
Und jetzt wird wahrscheinlich auch Axel Springer nicht so größenwahnsinnig sein dass sie glauben dass Google am Leistungsschutzrecht zugrunde gehen wird das heißt es geht um die kleineren Aggregatoren und der Sinn des Ganzen ist.
Große Verlage den Großteil ihrer Leserinnen und Leser durch direkte Besucher Ihrer Homepage bekommen.
Die kleinen Verlage aber vor allen Dingen durch sogenannten Will Ferrell Traffic also alles was über links kommt von Social Media Suchmaschinen Webseiten und so weiter.
Und das hatten die deutschen Verlage auch mal ganz gut dokumentiert also.
So vor 12 Jahren mal einen lustigen Streit mit Günther Oettinger auf Twitter wo so diverse Online-Redakteure mal ausgepackt haben und gesagt haben wo kommt eigentlich ihr Traffic her.
Da hat man halt gesehen also bei den großen Zeitungen wie FAZ war das so 70% direkte Besucher der Homepage und bei kleinen Regionalzeitungen und auch bei so spezielle Spezial.
Portalen wie heiße waren es dann er sich.
Central Traffic das heißt mit anderen Worten wenn man es schwieriger macht von Suchmaschinen und Social Media auf Verlags Angebote zu verlinken dann killt man damit die kleinen Verlage und das ist vielleicht auch Sinn der Sache.
Ja wie geht's jetzt weiter also du bist ja immer so schön optimistisch das finde ich auch sehr schön ich nehme an dass es nicht nur einfach so zur Schau gestellt sondern hast auch deine Gründe werden ja schon.
Gesagt okay jetzt ist ja mal was durch gefochten worden mit dem Frauen national wie kommt denn sowas eigentlich beim Parlament an.
Ja also ich glaube wirklich.
Wir das im Plenum am 4. Juli noch kippen können weil die meisten Abgeordneten die waren auch schon hier als die,
Satelliten und in den letzten Tagen höre ich doch häufiger so stimmen dass Leute sagen oh wir müssen doch ganz schön aufpassen dass das jetzt nicht zum Mac.
Da wird.
Und das ist ja schonmal eine gute Ausgangsposition also die Abgeordneten sind irgendwie auf das Thema aufmerksam geworden wir sind sich sehr wohl bewusst das Netz.
Sozial in my Europawahlen sind und dass die Öffentlichkeit hat schaut wie sie abstimmen werden,
und ich glaube was jetzt ganz ganz wichtig ist ist dass wir dieses Momentum nutzen und.
Irgendwie lautstark protestieren nicht nur auf der Straße auch irgendwie dafür sorgen dass das Thema weiter in den Medien bleibt also auch so diverse.
Youtuber die durchaus irgendwie so bei Jugendlichen der ganz große Reichweite haben haben das Thema aufgegriffen also LeFloid hat was dazu gemacht.
Meatman Jack der auch bei den,
der Protesten schon eine ganz wichtige Rolle gespielt hat und also es gibt ein paar internationale Youtuber wie z.b. Philip defranco und pewdiepie die dazu was gemacht haben und die haben also Millionen von views auf ihren Videos.
Und es gibt ja quasi so eine ganze Generation mit der vielleicht auch selbst wir gar nicht mehr so richtig in Kontakt sind die auf das Thema jetzt aufmerksam geworden sind und womöglich gar nicht wissen also was.
Machen können also ist vielleicht das erste Mal dass sie überhaupt irgendwie sich so mit politischem Protest auseinandersetzen und so.
Das heißt wir denken uns wir wollen das versuchen wirklich gegen das Thema zu protestieren als erstes gibt's jetzt am Sonntag eine Demo in Berlin.
Zu der rufen bislang auf also unter anderem die Electronic Frontier Foundation digital Courage die Piratenpartei die Grünen Energie Netzpolitik.
Und noch eine Reihe andere NGOs.
Wir haben auch weitere Parteien angefragt also es sieht so aus als ob das wirklich relativ breit und überparteilich werden könnte also die Demo beginnt jetzt diesen Sonntag 24. Juni um 11:45 Uhr.
Vor dem europäischen Haus der Unter den Linden 78 und.
Was ist direkt in HDD direkt in der Nähe vom Pariser Platz ne S-Bahn U-Bahnhof Brandenburger Tor wahrscheinlich oder sehe ich das richtig.
Glaube ich bin ein Weilchen nicht mehr in Berlin gewesen.
Ja ja das ist da.
Zentral und also die Demoroute geht eben vom europäischen Haus in Richtung axel-springer-haus dass ich auch ganz witzig finde und also es geht gegen upload-filter und gegen Leistungsschutzrecht.
Und also ich glaube das wird eine witzige Sache und hoffentlich kommt da auch wieder so ein bisschen Acta Stimmung auf und das Wetter soll auch gut werden also ich kann nur alle.
Aufrufen da vorbeizukommen das ist aber jetzt ist so der erste Versuch das Thema auf die Straße zu bringen daneben ist es natürlich jetzt ganz wichtig einfach die Abgeordneten zu kontaktieren.
Ich glaube.
In Deutschland ziemlich wichtig wäre die SPD die haben nämlich ausnahmsweise tatsächlich was richtig gemacht und im Rechtsausschuss gegen upload-filter und Leistungsschutzrecht gestimmt.
Das war aber letzten Endes nur eine Abgeordnete also bzw also.
2 von der SPD im Rechtsausschuss einen Vollmitglied und ein stellvertretendes das sind Silvia Kaufmann und Timo Wirth.
Und die haben sich bei dem Thema wirklich super klar positioniert und das ist toll und die sagen auch naja im Koalitionsvertrag steht Upload fehlt er sind unverhältnismäßig und dazu stehen wir.
Nur man sieht ja die Bundesregierung als ganze agiert durchaus anders und deshalb kann man sich jetzt nicht darauf verlassen das wirklich die gesamte SPD geschlossen am 4. Juli dagegen stimmen wird insofern wäre das.
Sehr wichtig da die Abgeordneten entsprechend zu kontaktieren also jetzt nicht unbedingt Silvia Kaufmann und Tiemo wölken weil die haben sich ja schon positioniert aber die anderen halt.
Und naja also bei der CDU kann man es auch probieren.
Und natürlich auch bei den anderen Parteien FDP grüne Linke wobei ich hoffe dass da die meisten sowieso schon dagegen sind.
Aber also das ist jetzt wirklich wichtig weil viele Abgeordnete Hand wahrscheinlich sich mit dem Thema noch überhaupt nicht.
Und wenn ihr jetzt doch irgendwie Anfragen von der Presse bekommen die sie eigentlich dazu stehen vielleicht von ihrer Lokalzeitung dann müssen sie sich dazu halt irgendwie verheilt.
Und insofern ja.
Und ansonsten eure regionalen Abgeordneten anrufen und die Lokalpresse fragen hey mach doch mal was dazu und was sagen eigentlich die Abgeordneten aus der Region.
Wir sind ja die Unterstützung so aus dem Lobbybereich also der Eco läuft ja auch schon Sturm gibt's in der Haupt noch andere Wirtschaftsorganisation die dann ins werde versuchen Einfluss zu aufzunehmen.
Also mitkommen ist natürlich auch dagegen.
Startup Verband also es gibt irgendwie Kaffeeverband deutsche-startups oder so aber die Industrie als Ganzes,
also es gab ab und zu schon solche,
solche Briefe auch aus Ecken wo man vielleicht nicht erwartet hätte also ich glaube Bosch z.b. hat uns irgendwann mal eine Mail geschrieben dass sie halt auch irgendwie in ihrer.
In ihrem Konzern Alltag auf Plattformen wie GitHub z.b. angewiesen sind und dass sie sowieso ganz verantwortungsbewusst.
Urheberrechte umgehen und dass solche Maßnahmen halt absolut unverhältnismäßig sind und irgendwie den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland gefährden.
Die ich hoffe dass die weiterhin irgendwie die CDU bearbeiten weil irgendwie so mit einem CDU Wirtschaftsminister das beeindruckt den vielleicht mehr wenn Bosch sagt dass es Unsinn als wenn das irgendwie.
Weiß nicht digital Courage sagt.
Ja ja oder man kann ja auch mal in einem mittelständischen Unternehmen arbeitet mal fragen wieso die Führungsriege eilig dazu steht irgendwie nicht auch mal den Telefon Oranier annehmen will sowas.
Ja also Wirtschaftsministerium Anfragen und Justizministerium ist definitiv eine gute Idee.
Gut 4. bis 5. Juli steht jetzt hier ist die ist dann die Abstimmung im Parlament.
Da kriegt das.
Also das wäre quasi die letzte Chance um diese urheberrechtsrichtlinie noch zu verbessern.
Denn wenn wir am 4. Juli verlieren dann bedeutet dass der Text den der Rechtsausschuss da jetzt angenommen hat wird,
die Position des Parlaments und dann steigt das Parlament unmittelbar in Verhandlung mit dem rad ein und dann ist natürlich klar der Rat hat sich ja schon für upload-filter und da ist.
Leicht ausgesprochen und wenn das Parlament das auch tut dann kann man nicht erwarten dass in den trilogverhandlungen noch irgendwas zum Besseren verändert wird.
Seid die Frage wo genau zwischen den beiden Positionen trifft man sich das heißt wenn wir am 4. Juli die Abstimmung verlieren,
dann gibt es nur noch eine Chance nämlich ganz am Ende der Verhandlungen wahrscheinlich im Frühjahr nächsten Jahres die gesamte Richtlinie abzulehnen.
Das wäre aber.
Meiner Ansicht nach schade weil es ja durchaus gute Elemente dieser Richtlinie gibt dass es gibt eine verpflichtende Schranke für Bildungszwecke damit Bildung.
Institutionen auch grenzübergreifend irgendwie im Internet Angebote machen können es gibt ein paar Erleichterungen für Bibliotheken es gibt einen Schutz der gemeinfreien Werke also dass man nicht mehr in wie,
das in der Vergangenheit z.b. passiert ist irgendwelche Museen Wikipedianer verklagen können weil sie irgendwie Fotos von gemeinfreien Gemälden aus dem 17. jahrhundert bei Wikipedia hochladen und solche Dinge.
Nur diese positiven Punkte sind halt im Vergleich zu den negativen so klein dass das jetzt irgendwie.
Am Ende nicht ausschlaggebend sein kann nur also es wäre sehr sehr viel erfolgreicher und sinnvoller.
Wenn wir diesen dieses Ergebnis aus dem Rechtsausschuss jetzt im Juli ablehnen weil dann können wir die positiven Elemente der Reform noch retten.
Und trotzdem die upload-filter abschaffen aber es ist nicht die allerletzte Chance also das heißt selbst wenn wir es im Juli nicht schaffen dann gibt es zumindest noch die Chance.
Ganz am Ende bei der Abstimmung des Parlaments über das Ergebnis aus dem Trilog die gesamte Richtlinie abzulehnen.
Ist das schon mal vorgekommen also das eine komplette Richtlinie vom Parlament abgewählt.
Ich bin mir also mir fällt jetzt spontan kein konkreter Fall ein,
aber naja also zwar keine Richtlinie aber zumindest halt das Acta Abkommen,
ist einfach abgelehnt worden allerdings hatte da das Parlament auch keine Möglichkeit Änderungsanträge zu machen also das war eine reine ja Nein Frage,
das ist da Handelsabkommen leider immer so und da hat das Parlament dann am Ende mit Nein gestimmt halt auch nach entsprechenden Protesten aus der Zivilgesellschaft.
Na gut was nicht ist kann ja vielleicht noch werden ich kann mir vorstellen dass es dir persönlich.
Da das ja alles Urheberrechte am Prinzip so deinen.
Projekt deiner Legislaturperiode war auch etwas weh tun würde aber ich glaube Wissen uns auch alle einig mit denen Änderungen die wir jetzt derzeit im Papier stehen haben wird keiner so richtig froh.
Absolut ja also ich glaube.
Es wäre schon sehr schade also wenn am Ende irgendwie die ganze Richtlinie scheitert aber das wäre dann eben nicht meine Schuld also ich habe alles getan um diese,
Vorschläge irgendwie auf eine sinnvolle Bahn zu leiten es ist auch nicht so als hätte ich,
in den Verhandlungen im Rechtsausschuss einfach gesagt irgendwie Leistungsschutzrecht und Artikel 13 wir streichen die jetzt einfach komplett.
Sondern ich habe konkrete Alternativvorschläge vorgelegt und gesagt okay.
Also das YouTube z.b. die GEMA bisher bezahlen soll das kann man schon fordern weil YouTube eben auch die Inhalte.
Erkennt also YouTube kann ja nicht behaupten ich wüsste nicht dass wir heute da Musik hochladen weil Content-ID findet diese Inhalte natürlich.
Und was was YouTube da macht ist im Grunde genommen.
Anstatt mit der Verwertungsgesellschaft zu verhandeln eben jedem einzelnen Urheber Song take it or leave it Angebot zu machen also du bekommst.
Diesen Anteil an den Werbeeinnahmen denen die wir dir zugestehen und wenn nicht dann bekommst du halt nichts und das ist natürlich in gewisser Weise.
Ja unfair weiß natürlich verhindert dass die Urheber gemeinsam verhandeln können das sehe ich auch ein und deshalb haben wir halt diesen diesen Alternativvorschlag den auch der.
Ausschuss für bürgerliche Freiheiten und für Verbraucherschutz schon angenommen hatten und der sagt eben also ok.
Bei solchen Plattformen die die User Upload wirklich monetarisieren müssen Sie für diese Uploads schon irgendwie eine Lizenz abschließen.
Also für die Arten von Uploads die sie entsprechend erkennen können aber es gibt eben ein Verbot von solchen Filter Verpflichtung.
Und das wäre auch einen Kompromiss gewesen der glaube ich in irgendeiner Form tragfähig gewesen wäre also der kam sogar auch ursprünglich aus der Fraktion von Herrn Voß.
Ideen hat polnischer EVP Abgeordneter namens Michael Bohny vorgeschlagen und genauso beim Leistungsschutzrecht also wir haben einen Alternativvorschlag auf dem Tisch,
der sein der ist schon den Verlagen erleichtert gegen wirklich im Urheberrecht Verletzung vorzugehen aber eben nicht irgendwie ein neues Recht schafft das das Verlinken im Internet behindert.
Wenn jetzt das Parlament am 4. Juli tatsächlich gegen diesen Beschluss des Rechtsausschusses stimmt was ist denn dann der Status der gesamten Initiative ist heißt das dann back to the drawing board und es gibt noch mal durch die Ausschüsse und man muss sich auch was anderes einigen oder beinhaltet diese Abstimmung quasi eine,
alternative Variante mit der dann in den Trilog geht.
Also die Abstimmung am 4. Juli beinhaltet erstmal keine alternative Variante das ist einfach nur eine ja Nein Frage.
Sind wir mit dem Ergebnis so zufrieden ja oder nein wenn die Mehrheit mit nein stimmt.
Dann können zur nächsten Plenarsitzung im September wieder Änderungsanträge eingereicht werden und dann können wir eben diese sinnvollen Kompromiss Vorschläge noch mal auf die Agenda bringen,
und ich glaube also wenn wir erstmal eine Mehrheit gegen den aktuellen Text gefunden haben.
Dann wird es auch relativ leicht sein entsprechend für diese Alternativvorschläge im mehr als zu finden denn im Rechtsausschuss war es genauso also alle die.
Gegen den Vorschlag von Herrn Voß gestimmt haben haben für meinen Gegenvorschlag gestimmt und umgekehrt also es gab jetzt keine die gesagt haben das ist alles Mist und.
Wir stimmen einfach gegen alles.
Gut schauen wir mal am 4. Juli ist zumindest kein WM Spiel ansonsten scheint.
Aber ist am 5. Juli 1 weil so.
Am 5. auch nicht.
Okay gut also es kann sein dass es,
auf den fünften verschoben wird aber wir gehen davon aus es ist am 4. und ja ich kann nur noch mal drauf hinweisen geht am Sonntag auf die Demo in Berlin wenn Ihr da seid und kontaktiert eure Abgeordneten am besten per Anruf.
In der kommenden Woche müsst ihr in Brüssel anrufen.
Und dann direkt vor der Abstimmung also Anfang Juli in der Woche sind wir in Straßburg da gibt's eine andere Telefonnummer.
Nach dieser alberne immer noch nicht abgeschafft worden es ist zum heulen naja diese Legislatur Julia vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Vielen Dank für den vielen Dank für dein Engagement und für die Zeit die du dir genommen hast und hier brandheiss darüber zu unterrichten.
Ja sehr gerne.
Vor allem viel Erfolg.
Sollte doch.
Chota wir bleiben bei.
Ärgernissen aus der EU die datenschutz-grundverordnung hat ja bei vielen Fürsorge.
Gesorgt dass man nun mit mit Abmahnungen übersät wird weil man gegen dieses.
Gesetz verstößt oder quasi Webseiten unterhält sie keine Datenschutzerklärung haben oder sonstiges war man ja nur zwei Jahre Zeit hatte sich,
auf die Gesetzesänderung vorzubereiten das geht natürlich so schnell nicht ne wenn wir 10 Jahre brauchen bis wir Datum Ansagen im Podcast kam natürlich von einem kommerziellen Unternehmen nicht innerhalb von zwei Jahren erwarten dass es sich an geltendes Recht hält.
Ja klar deswegen drohte das Risiko der Abmahnung.
Und da hat jetzt die haben die Abgeordneten des Bundestages der Regierung eine Frist bis zum 1. September gesetzt um einen Gesetzentwurf gebe gegen abmahnmissbrauch vorzulegen Denkmal.
Super man nun endlich weg wir wissen ja auch aus den Gesprächen.
Mit Thomas das dass es Länder gibt in denen es dieses abmahn Unwesen nicht gibt und die einzigen die die die einfache Lösung ist dass die erste Abmahnung eben nicht.
Strafbewehrt ist und nicht so hoch strafbewehrt haben das Problem in Deutschland die ganze Zeit mit diesen Abmahnung hier kommt aber der. Natürlich auch hier.
Mal so richtig das Problem lösen wollte man dann auch nicht sondern nur für die.
Datenschutz-grundverordnung bei nicht erheblichen und geringfügigen verstoßen gegen die datenschutzgrundverordnung dürfen keine kostenpflichtigen Abmahnung möglich sein wird gefordert aber.
Der Volker Ullrich von der CSU versicherte dass die Koalition auch möglichst schnell darüber sprechen würde wie das man Unwesen insgesamt eingehegt werden.
Körner.
Numb das man will sich der Sache also annehmen auf primär jetzt aber erstmal an der Stelle wo es bisher noch kein Problem so wirklich gibt den Massenabmahnung im datenschutzgrundverordnung Bereich haben wir ja bisher einfach nicht gesehen.
So wir haben vereinzelte versuche wo wahrscheinlich mal jemand gesagt hat sie probieren wir jetzt mal aber ich hier wie heißen diese die die Serienbrief Täter waldorf-frommer und so.
Na die haben das noch nicht bisher für sich entdeckt.
Serienbrief Dieter Zetsche.
Ja also uns ist auch unklar ob das noch passieren wird ich sag nicht wird nicht passieren soll nur wenn man bei den Juristen herum fragt gibt es halt schon.
Auch die These dass dass ich ihn mir anders verhält und kann weil Abmahnung halt Außenwirtschaft wird bewerbt rächt sich ableiten.
Dementsprechend argumentiert werden müssen ganze Datenschutz Geschichte er im Bereich Menschenrechte angesiedelt ist da lässt sich dieser Link nicht so ohne weiteres machen ne.
Also du musst quasi du musst als ab mahnende Instanz quasi sagen wieso dir einen Schaden oder einen Wettbewerbsnachteil entsteht.
Ja und ich habe keine Ahnung ob das nicht so immer jemand noch gelingt diese Brücke auch zu überqueren ja kann alles durchaus sein weiß ich nicht ist halt Juristen Realität nur ist es eben jetzt.
Offenbar nicht so ohne weiteres einfach zu macht so oder so ist es ganz interessant dass.
Du wollte eigentlich jetzt ausgeredet datenschutzgrundverordnung überhaupt mal für eine Debatte auch bei der CDU sorgt oder auch der CSU.
Also jetzt auf einmal interessiert sie das weil es jetzt vielleicht mal wirklich auch die Firmen betreffen kann so.
Bisher die Privatpersonen das waren dann eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Nee nee.
Mach das natürlich das schlimmste war.
Ja klar und das Feuer.
Menschen verletzen ist meistens und wie ok aber Rechte verletzen von.
Urheberrechte nee nee die gelten also die Urheberrechte sind wichtiger als Menschen das erkennt man daran dass sie sogar länger gelten als der Mensch.
Ja sogar noch länger über deinen Tod hinaus als Du vielleicht selber gelebt hast.
Transzendente Rechte.
Na vielleicht sollte es nur so lange gelten wie man selber bis dahin gelebt hat nee das auch doof.
Wir lassen gelassen führte woher.
Eine gute Idee.
Wir werden uns wieder der Überwachung zu.
Denn das hessische Verfassungsschutzgesetz wurde jetzt auch gestern am Donnerstag den 21 kurz abends durch gepumpt in namentlicher Abstimmung.
Mit den Stimmen von CDU und Bündnis 90 die Grünen.
Höfli Freiheit.
Wie war das noch mal öffnen sich dieser Mensch Schwarz-Grün der fährt zur seiner werden die Grünen aber standhaft für die Bürgerrechte einstehen wie wir sie aus der Bundespolitik kennen ne.
Klar logisch.
Da wir doch für die die die die Grüne Partei meine Güte die einigen die einen die sich bisher nicht von der CDU sondern nur von der SPD haben korrumpieren lassen.
Bündnis 90 steht für Freiheitsbewegung.
Ja die mit der Sonnenblume ja aber ärgerlich.
Bin in Hessen eben dann doch nicht sowohl Online-Durchsuchung als auch Quellen-TKÜ wird es dann jetzt in Hessen nach dieser Entscheidung des Landtags geben gemäß diesen Entwurf.
Muss Anwalt an zwei Stellen jeweils ein Richter zustimmen also erst bei der Genehmigung der Maßnahme dann bei der Verwertung der Daten.
Ich denke da also das ist zumindest mal einen nicht zu kritisieren da. Ja so das ist keine schlechte Idee.
Ansonsten wollen sie natürlich noch auf die Nutzungsdaten von Messenger Diensten zugreifen.
Was heißt denn genau an zwei Stellen.
Naja also 22 bestes axis.
Achso also den den achso ich dachte jetzt an zwei Richter unabhängig voneinander.
Nenanana.
Einrichter reicht aber in zwei l in zwei Stufen.
Das weiß ich nicht ob das zwei unterschiedliche Richter sein müssen aber du du kannst quasi sagen wir wollen jetzt diese Datenerhebung machen.
Oder sagt der Richter jawoll gibt macht mal und da müsste dann jetzt wollen wir die Daten die wir erheben erhoben haben wollen wir jetzt auch mal sehen,
und dann muss der Richter keine Richter noch mal sagen okay ich guck mir das jetzt noch mal an machen wir das hat aber natürlich auch zufolge dass die Schwelle für die Erhebung der Daten geringer ist weil du immer sagen kannst na ja.
Wir wollen mal auf Verdacht schon mal hier Trojan isieren und die Daten erheben.
Na sagte Richter ja ja okay mach mal ich kann euch ja immernoch nachher verbieten darauf zuzugreifen.
Ja aber wenn dann schon mal der Zugriff erlaubt wurde dann ne also das sind im es gibt ja immer den Unterschied zwischen wie.
Wie sinnvoll klingt das erstmal auf dem Papier und was ist dann nachher die gelebte.
Praxis und die gelebte Praxis wird hier natürlich eher sein dass die Schwelle für die Erhebung singt und dann wenn du schonmal heben erhoben wurde der Zugriff ebenfalls schneller durch geht ne.
Ansonsten Nutzungsdaten von Messenger Diensten wollte auch noch haben das durfte bisher nur bei Telefon und dass du bist natürlich dann auch für Gespräche möglich sein die über WhatsApp oder Skype geführt werden da wir sind mitunter wieder.
Weitreichende Konsequenzen.
So gab mir einen alten.
Sich phantastica gesagt aber einen alten Fall denn so alt ist er jetzt auch noch nicht also Ende letzten Jahres rund um den Kongress würde es auf einmal los das Besondere elektronische anwaltspostfach.
Revolutioniert die Kommunikation zwischen Juristen und Gerichten.
Dima auf XMPP Gesetz.
Man hätte nur in der E-Mail also lustigerweise hat mir das Heilweise auch ähnlich argumentiert aber.
Jetzt.
Also erinnern uns das anwaltspostfach sollte eingeführt werden wurde dann aber nicht eingeführt weil rund um den Kongress herum die Zweifel an der Sicherheit dann doch,
deutlich gestiegen dann gab es ein riesen Aufruhr dann würde das Rollout erstmal gestoppt und seitdem gab es verschiedenste versuche hier klar halten zu schaffen nur die Diskussion zu führen,
mit mir oder weniger Erfolg wurde versucht Experten mit in diesem Prozess mit einzubinden etc.pp jetzt gibt's wohl.
Ist alles ganz kurz erklärt in und und gut zusammengefasst in Logbuch nicht fertig 242 wo wir Markus drenger Zugangsdaten der uns das alles im Detail erklärt hat.
Und jetzt gibt's was neues ein Gutachten.
Ja zentrales zentrales Problem der is.
Das Bier ist dass es diesen einen Server gibt an dem.
Umgeschlüsselt wird das Haar also es sollte es auch noch schön sicher dass Hardware Security Module und so weiter aber.
Wir erinnern uns der Hintergrund war man wollte quasi keine direkt an Individuen verschlüsselte Kommunikation haben weil das.
Schwierigkeiten.
Bereiten könnte in der Delegation von Nachrichten also man sendet an Kanzlei hasse nicht gesehen.
Und dann soll ja der Sekretär die Nachricht genauso öffnen können wie die Anwältin.
Und diese Probleme wusste ja irgendwie in den Griff kriegen das könnte man natürlich der Kanzlei selber überlassen wie sie ihr key management regelt aber hier wurde eben gesagt na ja wir wollen z.b. auch,
an zentraler Stelle sowas wie eine Urlaubsvertretung machen das heißt du schreibst an deiner Anwältin die hat nur Urlaubsvertretung und dann wird das seid ihr woanders hingeschickt oder so na das hat deswegen einfach mal und,
und natürlich auch um das Problem zu lösen hier.
Was machen wir wenn die auf am ihre Schlüssel verlieren ne dann haben wir mit zum HSM natürlich die komfortable Möglichkeit das einfach zu ändern und auch mal retrograd noch mal schnell so ein paar Nachrichten umzuschlüsseln.
Sehr gut Umschlüsselung ist sehr komfortabel.
Kommt nichts abhanden.
Hat leider nur halt das Problem dass eben an einer zentralen Stelle alle Kommunikation eingesehen wird und.
Jetzt Wasser etwas ruhig jetzt hat ja secunet der,
mein an ein Unternehmen aus Deutschland da eine Analyse vorgenommen der Herren in 90 seitigen Bericht der war längere Zeit geheim oder nicht öffentlich hanno Böck hat den versucht über frag den Staat zu bekommen jetzt hat die Bragg die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer ihn selber veröffentlicht und da kann man im Prinzip sagen sekundär sagt allen Schwachstellen ist gemeinsam,
dass das HSM keinen oder keinen ausreichenden Schutz vor diesen Angriffen bietet das heißt Nachrichten bei erfolgreichem Angriff auch,
außerhalb des HSM entschlüsselt oder,
dem HSM Leseberechtigungen vorgetäuscht werden können das heißt die haben sogar noch mehr Schwachstellen gefunden als der Alz,
irgend,
Chaos Computer Club Darmstadt da in in der Freizeit entwickelt hat ne nur noch mal ein paar Experten darauf geworfen 90 Seiten Bericht dazu gekommen die hatten Halbzeit und Einsicht und so weiter haben also gesagt sieht alles noch viel viel.
Wie viel schlimmer aus die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte bei uns ja häufig erwähnt hat jetzt auch eine.
Klage dann eingereicht sie wollen sie wollen das Ding quasi sicher klagen soweit sind wir ja inzwischen als die Sicherheit müssen uns inzwischen er klagen und sagt also die die BFF klagt er jetzt mit dem Ziel.
Eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung so nachrüsten zu lassen dass allein die vorgesehenen Empfänger einer Nachricht diese entschlüsseln können fertig.
Und diese von der Bragg im Moment verwendet der Verschlüsselungstechnik gewährleistet dass eben nicht und hat eine Sollbruchstelle da hat also die GFF mal wieder sich ein paar Musterkläger da zusammengekratzt und versucht.
Hier ihrer ihrer Aufgabe als Chef Kläger der Freiheitsrechte gerecht zu werden.
Wir bleiben gespannt weil hieß der Hauptmann irgendwelchen Ideen der Bragg dieses dieses BH jetzt am 04.07 BMW in mehrstufigen Prozess irgendwie wieder in in Betrieb zu nehmen aber ich glaube die müssen auch noch mal irgendwie,
zur Fiebermessung gehen.
Ja schauen wir mal wieso sie digitalen internationalen Beziehungen zwischen Russland und USA sich so entwickeln.
Und der EU ja was war passiert gerade diese schönen Fall.
Wo 2015.
Timer NSA Tools von Rechner eines NSA Mitarbeiters gestohlen wurden weil der Sommer mal nicht unbedingt die Richtlinien seiner eigenen Behörde so.
Brigit eingehalten hat unter anderem so ein Keygenerator für Raubkopien auf seinem Rechner betrieben hat und das will ich auch diese Tools dort installiert hatte.
Und dadurch hat er sich dann halt selber Malware eingetreten.
Was hat seine Mama muss dazu sagen er hatte einen Erde ein Privatrechner.
Auf dem er nicht für Microsoft Office bezahlen wollte und hat dazu oder mit der einen Microsoft Office Lizenzkey bekommt ein kijin sich immer aus dem Internet gut der war mit einer Schadsoftware infiziert.
Des Weiteren hatte er seine Arbeitsmaterialien.
Nämlich NSA hacking Tools auch noch auf deinem Privatrechner und dann passierte folgendes der er infiziert hatte seinen Rechner mittels dieses key generate hast und sein Virenscanner war.
Kaspersky.
Und die haben eben wieder eine gesagt okay hier ist was haben dann erstmal diesen Keygenerator erkannt und haben dann weiterhin noch Hunger scannen auf den System und haben auch diese NSA Malware gefunden.
Und dann auch gleich noch mit übertragen.
Und beides schicken die dann zu sich nach Hause das ist auch also dass eine Funktion jeder Virenscanner hat wie sollen diese ganzen Virenscanner Forschungsunternehmen sonst ihre Forschung betreiben die schicken sich.
Verdächtige Dateien von den Rechnern ihrer Nutzer.
Nach Hause und untersuchen die dort ja also dass das ist nicht was nur Kaspersky macht.
Müssen.
Und.
Trotzdem geil.
Diese Funktion kannst auch abschalten hat der NSA Mitarbeiter aber nicht gemacht oder nicht gewusst und.
Die also so ist es eben nachweislich sind dann eben diese,
diese Daten diese NSA hacking Tools in die Hände von kasperske geraten die dann sogar noch beteuert haben sie haben die Daten gelöscht und nicht an Dritte weitergegeben wobei sie natürlich also ich meine das.
Wo ich sage so okay in dem Moment habt ihr mein Vertrauen verspielt wenn ihr Malware findet dann erwarte ich dass ihr die gefunden habt und die im nächsten Update meiner Signaturen bei mir keine Chance mehr hat das haben sie nicht getan ja.
Super.
Was wo ich jetzt sagen würde das ist der Grund euch nicht mehr zu vertrauen weil ihr offenbar hier mit der der NSA Sonderrechte eingeräumt hat.
Die Amerikaner haben das Ding aber irgendwie mitbekommen und sind seitdem irgendwie auf den Trichter und Zanjani hier die dieses Kaspersky exkulpiert Daten.
Und das dürfte dürft ihr nicht benutzen ne das war auch habe auch letztes Jahr glaube ich schon drüber berichtet dass die USA quasi inorder haben an ihre Annan sämtliche.
Behörden dass sie keinen Kaspersky benutzen dürfen und.
Ich hätte gesagt dass wir das EU-Parlament eine Entschließung Formulieren von der momentan der einen Entwurf kursiert und dieser das ist der.
Da geht es um den Entwurf einer Entschließung des Europäischen Parlaments zur cyberabwehr,
und das ist einfach wunderbar formuliert diese Ursachen hat er dann immer jede Zeile damit die zeilenweise übersetze können syrische sagt das europäische,
Parlament unter Hinweis auf den Vertrag der Europäischen Union unter Hinweis auf das was er will sie sowieso Gesetz für außen und Sicherheitspolitik Kasse als nicht gesehen und unter Hinweis auf das reflexionspapier,
über die Zukunft der europäischen Verteidigung und unter Hinweis auf das Tallinn manual 2.0 für internationales Recht in Cyber Operationen und so weiter kommen erstmal weiß nicht 30 Hinweise auf diese sich beziehen,
dann komm einmal von A bis bis A.
Erwägungen die Irani erkennt dass es nicht hexadezimal gezielt sondern von A bis Z und dann von AA bis ai so viele Erwägungen kommen.
Großartig die machen quasi blockchain Gesetzgebung ne also die ist das Gesetz der Bezug auf alle anderen nehmen.
Wenn man den jetzt noch erzählt dass sie die Funktion nehmen können dann wollen die demnächst der die Gesetzes blockchain machen.
Da wäre ja auch durch da wird ja auch immer durchaus was für sprechen.
Und und dann dann kommen 77 Forderungen.
Das ist für keinen Text da wirst du doch bescheuert R70 Forderung von denen eine im lautet fordert des EU Parlament.
In Bezugnahme auf und so weiter fordert die EU auf die Software die IP und Kommunikationsgeräte sowie die entsprechenden Infrastrukturen,
in den Organisationen eingesetzt werden einer umfassenden Überprüfung zu unterziehen um die Verwendung potenziell gefährlicher Programme und Geräte ausschließlich und die Verwendung als böswillig eingestufte Programme und Geräte wie Kaspersky Lab,
verbieten ja jetzt wollen die also jetzt will das EU-Parlament diesen Kaspersky Virenscanner verbieten.
Aber müssen Sie hier auch alle fest verbieten.
Die müssten eigentlich Computer verbieten aber ich finde das sehr interessant weil jetzt geht's natürlich sowieso die Debatte ok braucht man einen Virenscanner oder nicht.
Erhöht der Virenscanner das Risiko oder senkt er das Risiko eines Gerätes kompromittiert zu werden lange lange Debatten.
Selbstverständlich ist der Virenscanner selber wie jede andere Software auch eine Angriff Oberfläche für diesen Rechner ist noch dazu eine attraktive Angriffs Oberfläche weil er mit besonderen.
Privilegien im System arbeitet der Virenscanner muss ja quasi in in die Speicher reinschauen können der läuft also mit den höchsten verfügbaren rechten die auf dem,
Rechner möglich sind und er hat auf alles.
Zugriff und er greift auch auf alles zu weil er ja alle Speicherinhalte alle ausführbaren Dateien und so weiter quasi aufgefahren abgleichen muss das ist das.
Technische Risiko des Betriebes eines Virenscanners wenn also der Virenscanner eine Schwachstelle hat die sich in diesem Rahmen ausnutzen lässt dann lässt sie sich sehr leicht ausnutzen.
Weil er sowieso mit einem in Kontakt kommt und zweitens sind unter Umständen resultieren im Privilegien für den Angreifer eben sofort Ruth bzw System.
Soviel zum technischen Teilen gleichzeitig schütze Dich aber vor was weiß ich 100 tausend oder Millionen bekannter gefahren die da draußen im Internet kursieren das ist also ich in der Abwägung.
Die alle die Person für sich selber treffen müssen oder die wie gesagt hat das ist schlangenöl ja das ist in zu gewissen Teilen,
sicherlich war ich denke man kann aber durchaus also ich persönlich würde mich nicht trauen Leuten zu sagen verzichte auf einen Virenscanner ja weil ich den,
ehrlich gesagt glaube dass Leute sich ohne Virenscannern Pfeife 2er einen Schaden einfahren als mit Virenscannern zumal die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass.
Ein ein krasses Zero-Day-Exploit in einem Virenscanner ausgerechnet als allererstes an meiner Oma verballert wird dann doch auch relativ geringes ja,
also lassen wir die Debatte um um den Sinn oder Unsinn von Virenscannern mal kurz außen vor der bzw können dann kann in den Kommentaren geführt werden.
Spannend finde ich hier dass alle Virenscanner diese Probleme gemein sind.
Ja die haben alle das gleiche das gleiche systemische Problem und die gleichen vor und nachteile und sie haben alle auch diese Funktion mit dem beschicken mal Dateien auf Verdacht nach hause.
Und natürlich ist das unheimlich es ist aber nicht so als würde als würde nur Kaspersky das tun und was soll hier was hier also jetzt gibt was was hier stattfindet ist nach meiner Beurteilung eine.
Eine eine Kritik eines bestimmten Herstellers.
Aus politischen Erwägungen man sagt ja die App die Arbeiten bestimmt mit dem FSP zusammen,
ja ich hätte jetzt keinen Grund nichts davon auszugehen dass Norton oder oder McAfee oder wer auch immer da jetzt gerade der der schlangenöl Fabrikant ist nicht mit der NSA zusammen arbeitet ja also das.
Sollte man sich eben genau über hähnchenfächer will man mehr Angst hat.
Aber es ist schon ziemlich überraschend wenn diese Debatten über,
IT Sicherheit wenn wir an dem Punkt sind dass sie nicht mehr technisch fundiert geführt werden sondern dass sie politisch geführt werden.
Und das ist finde ich hier das alarmierende Signal das Gute ist Kaspersky wird wahrscheinlich billiger.
Kaspersky hat außerdem eine in einer Reaktion die mussten ja auch darauf reagieren haben dann eine eine nachricht dazu abgegeben wo sie dann sagen naja okay wir arbeiten gehen wir seit längerer Zeit sehr gut mit mit Europol und mit wem ich alles zusammen,
und irgendwie doch ärgerlich wenn wir das jetzt in Zukunft nicht mehr tun können ne also das ist.
Skurril was da stattfindet.
Ja vor allem hier hat man ja auch noch so die Möglichkeit auf einzelne zu schießen ich denke mal wie einmal bei Abwehr ist in zuzunehmen Maße auch ein Betriebssystem Thema.
Also und Mac OS kommt irgendwie Malware Scanner einfach bei default so gibt es einfach ne sprechende Funktion im Betriebssystem.
Kein Maulwurf genießen trotz seiner Arbeit egal.
Nenne es gibt auch Mahlwerk einer.
Wo wurden.
Iqos.
Wo wo kann man in abschalten.
Den kannst du mir abschalten.
Nein dir du mal was du meinst ist dieses aus vertrauenswürdigen Quellen dass die kontrollieren kurzweiligen.
Ich rede davon dass die wirklich Signaturen von bestimmten.
Ja genau kurz seinen.
Netz bezieht sich nicht nur auf kurz einige sonst bezieht sich halt auch auf Sachen die nicht über kurzzeitigen ausgeliefert werden also wenn läuteten kannst das ja auch nach wie vor abschalten und sagen dir darf alles exekutiert werden und dann.
Greift auch noch das Wand wann auch immer mal wieder so mal wer auf dem Mac die Runde macht dann ist Apple relativ schnell dabei,
das über Software Updates automatisch forcierte Software Updates auf die Systeme zu bringen und den Ausbruch davon im Griff zu heiß.
Ich kann dir jetzt nicht sehr viel technischer Einblicke darin geben wie das genau funktioniert aber diese Funktion gibt es und weiß man auch.
So nur was ich sagen wollte ist dass es jetzt Sommer mal nichts was man dem Sinne deinstallieren kann so und welche welche Angst hat man denn jetzt immer irgendwie anfangen und jetzt vor den USA zu fürchten ja müssen wir das nicht also max abschalten.
Was mit also keine Ahnung wie fandest du bei Windows auch schon Teil des Systems ist.
Beilngries eigentlich könnte man ja auch sagen na ja so eine Resilienz Willmann in zunehmendem Maße auch von einem Betriebssystem her' erwarten ohne daneben noch auf Sonderdienste von.
Drittanbietern Fotografin zum essen.
Es gibt übrigens ich sehe gerade noch von Jürgen Schmidt bei Heise den Artikel wo er sagt der.
Ja der Chef des research und Analyse Teams von Kaspersky sagt was wir finden veröffentlichen wir auch immer.
Und in NRW nimmt eine Reihe an Beispiel ich zitiere im März dokumentierten sie mit Slingshot eine gezielte Malware Kampagne gegen Isis,
und al-Qaida Mitglieder die mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit vom joint Special Operations command this,
US amerikanischen Militärs durchgeführt wurde mit super kennt ahnte Kaspersky Lab im Mai eine Android Malware dem iranischen Geheimdienst zugeschrieben wird und Iran ist ein Staat,
Mit dem Ausland freundschaftliche Beziehung pflegt auch in Europa Kaspersky bereit staatliche Cyber Operation intanto enthüllten sie mehrfach Aktivitäten der equation group NSA also in diesem Fall ging es ja und origin,
also die bei Belgacom gefunden Trojaner des ICE AGE cue,
na ja da steht doch die von Kaspersky detailliert beschriebene Malware origin wurde oder reghin oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht wurde bei Belgacom gefunden.
Und der wurde nachhaltig.
Nachhaltig geackert und das ist natürlich also.
Mann Mann Mann was ich hier quasi und Unheil am Horizont wenn jetzt hier Main-Kinzig eine Lanze für Kaspersky brechen und sagen ok die haben arbeiten mit niemanden zusammen oder die Arbeiten mit irgendjemanden zusammen wie auch immer.
Aber wenn ohne sind sinnvolle Hinweise hier solche Kampagnen gegen,
Sicherheit die Sicherheitsunternehmen gefahren werden da gibt es eigentlich keine Gewinner bei.
Und das ist ein trauriges Kraut traurig.
Muss wieder aufzuheitern schalten wir jetzt direkt um zu den Terminen.
Am Montag den 25.06 um 18 Uhr wird die bayerische Landesvertretung umzingelt da geht es um einen Protest mit dem die Hedonistische Internationale,
und zwar die Sektion Homeland Security Böllen sich gegen den heimathorst richten.
Möchte also unter dem Motto Horst komm raus du bist umzingelt.
Wird das wird erst die Landesvertretung umzingelt und im Anschluss traditionelle Berliner Tänze vor dem Brandenburger Tor aufgeführt.
Aber nicht nur im Süden darf demonstriert werden das geht natürlich auch im Westen und zwar konkret gegen das,
Polizeigesetz das vorgeschlagene in NRW was ja versucht in die Fußstapfen der bayerischen Gesetzesinitiative,
zu treten und abgesehen von zahlreichen kleinen Demos an verschiedenen Orten die in den nächsten Tagen stattfinden werden gibt's eine.
Abschluss Großdemo am 7. Juli in Düsseldorf unter www.polizei-nrw.de.
Könnt ihr da alle Termine einsehen und schauen wir euch da einbringen könnt.
Am 5 bis 8 Julias am gleichen Wochenende in Hamburg wird gefeiert ein Jahr nach G20 das Festival der grenzenlose Solidarität mit Workshops einer großen Demonstration am 8.
Rave Aktionen und einem Fest.
Aber auch in Berlin gibt's was zu tun ist noch ein bisschen hin 17 und 18 November 2018 in der Technischen Universität Berlin gibt es eine Konferenz für Digitalisierung und Nachhaltigkeit einen schönen Titel.
Bits und Bäume hier finden sich Aktivisten für ökologische soziale und ökonomische Nachhaltigkeit.
Und digitalen Menschenrechtler zusammen und ja versuchen alle Themen zu besprechen die hier eine Rolle spielen könnten weil sich diese Bereiche ja zunehmendem Maße überlappen ja.
Strom intelligente Netze so nachhaltige Stromerzeugung intelligente Netze it all das wollen wir in diesem Community zusammenbringen.
Meldet euch bis zum 19. August bei Bits und Bäume. Org.
Und vom 22 bis zum 23. September 2018 in Dresden finden die Datenspuren statt die haben wir hier oft erwähnt und empfohlen der CST ist jetzt eröffnet.
Der call for participation und den findet ihr auch bei uns in den Links.
Ja und die Dresdner die haben auch noch ein anderes Anliegen.
Die Dresdner haben noch ein anderes Anliegen und zwar ist der C3 D2 umgezogen in das,
zentralwerk vor einiger Zeit des zentralwerk ist eine Genossenschaft die in Dresden etwa 70 Ateliers unterhält.
Die also von Verein wie dem Chaos Computer Club Dresden dem internationalistischen Zentrum dem coloRadio und Künstlerin genutzt werden und dieses zentralwerk hat auch einen sehr großen Saal.
Was oder schmal.
Wenn ich jetzt dann wenn Datenspuren wahrscheinlich sein dass hat einen großen Saal von dem kann sich auch Bilder anschauen ist ein so ein ehemals der prächtiger Saal.
Da hätten sie eigentlich auch gerne Datenspuren 2018 gemacht aber der hat keine Lüftungsanlage und das macht die Nutzung dieses Saales eben,
zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten des Jahres relativ,
schwierig und jetzt Lüftungsanlage ist immer eine erstaunlich teure Angelegenheit und gehen jetzt davon aus dass sie hier sowas wie 30000 € brauchen.
Und eine ordentliche Lüftungsanlage in diesem Saal zu bauen um dann aber eben eine Rest kann man so machen einen schönen,
Veranstaltungssaal für die Stadt Dresden zu haben indem eben diese Kultur betonte Genossenschaft.
Florian kann Veranstaltung anbieten kann vielleicht eben die Datenspuren 2019 abhalten kann und wer da Interesse hat in der Stadt wohnt und da ein,
neuen Ort für die Kultur unterstützen möchte ist herzlich gebeten sich an der.
Camp Crowdfunding-Kampagne 30 riesen nur für heiße Luft zu beteiligen.
Das ist doch schon ganz gut aus wenn man da mal drauf schaut ja also von den 30000 zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme dieser Sendung 19000 450 Euro bereits Geplätscher.
Bei mir steht 20 Uhr 1662.
Dann muss ich vielleicht mal kurz reload machen und da steht bei mir 20 000 842.
Also irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Da rollt irgendwie auf jeden Fall schon ganz ordentlich rein sprich noch 9 Tage aber ich habe so den Eindruck das könnte was werden 30000 € im übrigen kostet nicht die Anlage 30000 € ist das was dazu gegeben werden muss damit.
Von der Stadt getragen wird also das könnte ich mir ganz gut vorstellen und wie sieht das richtig dass die Datenspuren auch dann da schon in diesem Jahr stattfinden sollen.
Die sind in der Technischen Universität glaube ich oder einen.
Weil das steht nämlich auf der Webseite steht tatsächlich dort.
Ja dann können Sie dann können Sie den Saal nicht nutzen also ich sehe er doch genau das ist in zentralwerk es könnte sein ich nur.
Tolle Sache sozusagen.
Genau weil der Saal ohne Lüftungsanlage nicht als Veranstaltungsort zugelassen wird und dann sagen wir unser zweites fundingziel.
Wenn sie 40.000 zusammenkriegen dann können Sie da auch noch eine Heizung dran anschließen das ist alles relativ teuer aber.
Na ja gut das ist ja auch ich weiß nicht wie groß dieser Saal ist aber wenn er so toll ist und Heizungsanlage chris hat man nicht eben für ein paar.
Das ist ein bisschen relativ großer Saal der hat auch historische Bedeutung da gibt's dann irgendwie hier.
Sed Versammlung.
Das Ei Gebäude wurde 1940 als letztes Gebäude des Rüstungsbetrieb,
güllewerk der Zeiss Ikon AG als sogenanntes Gemeinschaftshaus errichtet und dann wurde es halt irgendwie bis 19 45 weil das gesamte Betriebsgelände mit einer zwei Meter hohen Mauer eingefasst nach 45 wurde der Saal wieder genutzt eine wichtige Kulturstätte im Krieg zerstörten Dresden das ist jetzt nicht irgendeine,
Turnhalle könnt ihr euch mal anschauen wenn ihr in Dresden sitzt und.
Oder Umgebung und denkt dass das eine Städte werden könnte die besten bereichert dann schaut euch doch mal das Crowdfunding an.
Gut das bringt uns zum Ende der Sendung das war ganz nett.
Nette gestern gehabt.
Genau vielen Dank noch mal an Julia für ihre immerfort eloquenten Ausführungen und die hatten ungebrochenen Optimismus.
Ja eklig.
Es wird sowas was erlaube was erlaube Julia wieder.
Obwohl wir allen anders hatten haben wir das nur geschafft indem wir uns kaum über irgendwie Donald Trump.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr nein nein nein nein nein ist ja jetzt auch Sommer.
Aufgeregt haben das mal jetzt nicht mehr heimathorst ist ja dann den Heimatort entfernt dann am Montag schon die Hedonistische Internationale und dann sieht es auch wieder besser aus.
Genau und dann Gewerbe Weltmeister noch mal wir ist in dem Zusammenhang.
Wann ist das vorbei also diese Vorrunde.
Irgendwann Ende Juli sollen Mitte Juli.
Dann haben wir das ja hinter uns.
Gibt's immer was wir sagen tschüss habt Spaß bei allem was ihr tut.
Ciao ciao.